[Music]
hello Google cloud next how's it been
doing good all right lunch session
everyone's eaten Wally talk this is good
brown bag lunch all right so welcome to
getting started with containers and
google kubernetes engine we have 50
minutes to give as many details as we
can about gke to make you all experts
before we begin quick show of hands how
many people have ever deployed an app to
kubernetes before not that many that's
exactly what this session is all about
then so my name real quick intro my name
is Weston Hutchins I'm a product manager
on gke and I'm Anthony Bhushan a
customer engineer specialist focusing on
app dev and kubernetes so everyone said
they hadn't deployed we're gonna go
straight through demo no slides show you
how easy it is to get started take it
away Anthony all right thanks Wes so
today we're gonna demonstrate again how
easy it is to get a few containers up
and running on google kubernetes engines
so let's just dive right into it what
you're looking at here is a Google Cloud
console that is highlighting a
kubernetes engine cluster I've already
created this if you haven't created a
kubernetes engine cluster before it just
takes a few clicks or a simple g-cloud
command or even a simple terraform
resource it's actually quite simple um
but since we already have this let's
actually how do we use this cluster so
I'm gonna click on this connect button
and I'll actually get an auto-generated
g-cloud command to fetch credentials to
be able to interact with this cluster
and via coop control so G cloud is our
SDK so you'll see here that I have a GK
cluster but that's not the one we want
to use we want to use this one so this
great so now let's test that we've
actually connected to our kubernetes
cluster by getting the nodes that
comprise our cluster
and there we go so as you can see here
are the three nodes that comprise the
cluster that I showed you earlier at the
end of the day these are just virtual
machines right what's different is that
kubernetes allows us to interact with
these VMs in a better cleaner way so
we're not going to SSH into these nodes
we're not going to write imperative
instructions to actually install our
application instead once our app is
built in containers all we have to do is
write some declarative kubernetes
manifests and these containers that
comprise our application will be
scheduled by communities somewhere on
these three nodes right so the
application we'll be working with today
is comprised of an angular UI a goaling
API and a Postgres database and two
containers they allow us to package and
isolate these components independently
it really enables a concept of micro
services and so within that design each
of these components has their own code
and their own docker file which
specifies how to build the image into a
container and so as I mentioned once
these containers are built all we need
are kubernetes manifests to implement
our desired state in the cluster
so let's actually look at what that
looks like so in the CMO file is our
kubernetes manifest and this is for the
UI aspect of our application so what
you'll see here is that we're telling
kubernetes that we want a load balancer
to actually front a what is called a
kubernetes pod that is based on this
template now a kubernetes pod is a
grouping of 1 or n containers so in this
case our UI pod is going to run our UI
and our API containers and we want to
replicas of that pod cool the magic of
kubernetes is that once we provide this
desired state criminals will a implement
it and be take action at all times to
reconcile the observed state with the
desired state that we have here so let's
get this application up and running we
have to build a container image we have
to apply the manifest to kubernetes and
we're going to use scaffold which is a
tool that was built an open source by
the amazing container tools T team here
at Google we're going to do all of it
with a single command
let's look at that and that command is
scaffold dev great so we'll see that all
the steps that I'd mentioned are now
being kicked off by this tool well dive
into the details of scaffold a little
bit later in the talk but while it's
doing its thing West I wanted to ask you
how familiar are you with our GCP logos
not not really at all okay well it's a
good thing then that our demo
application is actually a quiz so we
have a pop quiz for you to see if you
can match the product or use case with
it's appropriate GCP hexagons so now we
see that this application is actually
deployed we're gonna have to before we
get into the app let's look at the
kubernetes resources that were created
so I think before we mentioned that we
want pods so let's look at those great
so we have two replicas of the UI pod
and then one replica of the Database pod
I didn't show that manifest but that was
also recursively applied as it was in
the kubernetes manifest folder we also
will be able to look at the load
balancers so right now gke in the back
end is actually provisioning a network
load balancer to front ru ipods and so
you'll see that it's actually also
provisioning an external IP address
again this is really the magic of
cribben at ease all we have to do is
write these declarative files and we get
our desired state so let's look at that
again and we'll see that we now have an
external IP address to access our
application so let's throw that into our
browser and wes this is made just for
you so you're on the spot now
I hope you didn't practice this at all
and I failed Management Service I I'm
gonna go with one on the left's for that
one hey I don't know you shared
something alright that's correct
let's run it again in cloud tools for
Android studio I don't think it's either
of those but probably the one on the
left as well okay so this is a
placeholder for once I actually don't
have a hexagon okay all right one more
time let's do one more as it's run a
different one this one also does not
have a
there you go it's a debugger debugger is
gonna be the one all right awesome
hey how about a round of applause for
Wes I passed yeah thank you
quite a bit so it's clear that Wes and
those GCP but what's also clear is that
it can be really easy to get up and
running with containers and kubernetes
engine so let's quickly recap what this
demo did we had a gke cluster again this
is really easy to create with a single
click we've connected to this cluster we
built our applications in containers
we've declaratively deployed them to
kubernetes and we've exposed those
containers behind a load balancer so
that we could all go through the demo
today and so and Wes again ace the GCP
quiz so we did this all with scaffold
and google kubernetes engine in just a
few commands and so today we'll show you
how to get started really easily with a
lot of the things that you'll need to do
to be able to have a demo like this
so back to you Wes cool thank you so I
know that was a quick
you probably had us all a lot of things
on-screen that you didn't quite
understand we're gonna go into a bunch
of the the mo file definitions and kind
of how we build this out and a little
bit later can we jump back to the slides
cool all right
so a brief history of containers and
kubernetes soup containers have been
around for a long time
they've been a part of Linux for for
quite quite a while we really started to
see container adoption pick up with the
introduction of docker in about 2013 and
that was a key moment where public
adoption of containers really started to
take off docker offered a lightweight
container runtime and an amazing
packaging and deployment model where you
could bundle your app and all its
dependencies and deploy that
consistently across different
environments now when docker came out
they were really focused on that dev
workflow and solving the packaging and
deployment for a single node across the
single container as well and we all
realized that it wasn't the full
solution the eventual goal would be to
manage that manage multiple containers
across many different nodes and that's
when kubernetes really started to the
seeds of kubernetes start
planted at Google was around 2013
timeframe so kubernetes really at its
heart is an orchestration tool now what
does that mean it really means that you
can package and deploy multiple
containers across multiple hosts and
kubernetes takes care of most of the
heavy lifting for you with things like
scheduling an application health
checking and more of those types of it
or more of those types of things but in
my opinion kubernetes is really two
powerful concepts the first is that it's
an abstraction over infrastructure and
this is really really important for your
developers we wanted to make it so that
most developers didn't really have to
retrain their skills depending on
whatever cloud they were using or if
they wanted to move from something on
Prem over to a cloud platform as well
kubernetes gives you that consistent
base layer that allows the operators to
worry about infrastructure and the
developers to get a consistent tooling
platform and the second real powerful
tool of kubernetes is that it's a
declarative API everything in kubernetes
is driven off this model of declare your
state declare what you want to have
happen and then kubernetes has built-in
feedback loops that will make that state
reality and they're constantly observing
we can write even custom controllers to
handle a bunch of different state
reconciliations for even new objects
that you want to create and the best
part about kubernetes is that it tries
to encapsulate a bunch of best practices
around application deployment and and
scheduling so things like where does a
particular container need to get
scheduled on which node is that node
healthy can I do
can I restart that node if it goes down
how do I provision storage we have
storage providers for a number of
different platforms built into
kubernetes through the through the
ecosystem logging and monitoring is also
integrated and we've seen a lot of
extensibility with tools like Prometheus
and Garr fauna that work on top of the
kubernetes system and even going so far
as things like identity and
authorization there's a ton of work that
happens in the community every month on
adding new and new features to the
platform it's it's actually quite
astounding how fast
Nettie's iterates and it's really
important to always make sure you're
keeping up with the latest developments
but with great power comes great
responsibility i'm kubernetes can be a
bit overwhelming there's a lot of power
under the hood here and there is
inherent complexity with the system as
powerful as kubernetes and when we talk
to users
we typically you know break people up
into two camps one is people that are
operating the cluster cluster operators
and the second one is application
developers and from a cluster operator
perspective installing kubernetes is
relatively straightforward the real pain
comes when you have to manage the day to
operations this is things like setting
up security and TLS between my nodes
encrypting at CD and making sure that no
one can access it doing disaster
recovery like backup and restore and
even things like node lifecycle
management if a node goes down these are
all things that cluster operators don't
always like to handle themselves and we
see a lot of questions and forum posts
on how to operate kubernetes at scale
one of the key missions of gke when it
first came out was to take the heavy
lifting off of the cluster operators and
give it to Google and that's really the
big power of google kubernetes engine is
that we wanted to offer this fully
managed solution where Google runs your
clusters and you as the developers get
to focus on the applications so gke is
our hosted cloud managed kubernetes
solution we were GA in August of 2015 so
we've been running a number of
production clusters for three years now
one of the nice things about gke is that
we take upstream kubernetes and we ought
we try to keep as close to upstream as
possible and are always releasing new
versions of gke as new versions of
kubernetes are coming out but we wanted
to add deep integration with GCP so we
make it really easy to use other
features like logging and monitoring and
identity right out of the box with
kubernetes and gke
so let's look at the architecture of how
gke is deployed on top of GCP so there's
typically two parts to kubernetes two
major parts to kubernetes we have the
control plane and then
we have the nodes that make up your
cluster and on gke the control plane is
a fully managed control plane controlled
by Google we run this in our own project
and we have a team of site reliability
engineers that are constantly doing
things that I described on the day to
operations they're scaling the clusters
their health checking it they're backing
it up they're making sure that Etsy D is
always upgraded with the latest and
greatest security patches this is really
the operational burden taken off of the
end user and put into the hands of the
Google engineers there are two ways to
spin up the control plane for gke we
have the classic way which is zonal
where we spin up a single node and just
recently you announced general
availability of regional clusters which
allows you to spin up a multi master
high availability control plan which
I'll cover in a couple of the later
slides now the second piece are the
nodes and these run in your project
these are where you're actually going to
deploy your containers and we call these
the workers of the kubernetes cluster
now on gke we have a concept of node
pools which is a group of homogeneous
machines with the same configuration
I'll talk about that on the next slide
for these nodes we are the only cloud
platform to offer a fully managed node
experience and what that means is that
we provide the base image we constantly
keep it updated and we have features
like no doubt or repair and node auto
upgrade that allow you your cluster to
keep revving with the latest and
greatest upgrades without having you to
do anything at all so node pools are
also a gk concept and this is there's a
lot of advantages to building out things
with node pools so node pools are really
just a group of related machines it's
the same configuration if I could have
an n1 standard run instance I can create
a node pool of size three and that will
give me three in one standard run
instances now what's neat about node
pools is that it makes it really easy to
mix and match different instance types
so you can spin up note pool a with the
standard configuration then you can add
a second node pool with things like
preemptable VMs or GPUs so that you can
target specific workloads to those node
pools even better node pools make it
really really easy to add availability
to your application so if I'm running in
a
Engels own let's say us central 1b and I
want to add a failover to u.s. central
1a all you have to do is create a new
node pool in that new zone and then
attach it back to the cluster and this
is just a really nice way to group
related instances together and then
scale out your application so let's
actually walk through what happens when
you upgrade a node one of the features
that we offer to GK customers is this
feature called maintance windows now
maintenance windows give it's basically
you telling us a four-hour window when
we are allowed to upgrade your notes so
if you have high traffic during the day
and you want to make sure that upgrades
happen at midnight or whatever you can
specify this window we will only upgrade
to your master or your notes during that
timeframe so what happens is we will go
and drain a node and what this does is
it removes traffic from that node and
then we do an operation in communities
called cordon which makes it so that new
pods don't get scheduled to that node at
this point we spent up a new VM on the
latest version of kubernetes and then we
attached it back to your cluster so we
do this one by one in a rolling upgrade
fashion there is a couple other ways to
upgrade that I'm going to cover in a
little bit later but that's generally
how most of our users keep their notes
healthy and up-to-date
the other feature that we offer for node
management is node auto repair and no
two auto repair is basically a health
checking service there's a lot of
reasons why nodes can go down whether
it's kernel panics or disk disk errors
out of memory errors etc node out of
repair is constantly monitoring the
health of your cluster for particular
errors and if the health check fails
like it does here and it goes into a not
ready state it will go and do the same
operation that we did during upgrade
where we'll drain the node we'll spin up
a new one and then we'll reattach it
back to the cluster this makes it really
easy to make sure that your your nodes
are always healthy and at the set amount
that you want in your cluster and as I
said all of this is really the end
journey to get you to focus on the
things that matter which is your actual
application development and let Google
do the heavy lifting for kubernetes cool
with that I'm going to hand it back to
Anthony who's going to go into much more
depth on the building deploy lifecycle
awesome thanks Wes
so 18 minutes into the session and we
finally have reached the title of our
talk so we're going to talk about
getting started with containers in
kubernetes engine and these are the key
concepts that we'll be discussing today
all focused again around the second
narrative of actually using and
deploying things to kubernetes so let's
start with building and deploying
containers so when it comes to this
space there are two key areas we want to
consider one is enabling developers and
two is automating deployment pipelines
into environments like staging or
production and both are important but
let's start with the developers so for
developers who are new to technologies
like containers and kubernetes this is
often what the workflow feels like
initially there's a lot of unknowns the
magic in the middle could be docker run
cube CTL apply bash grips make files a
whole bunch of different approaches and
this can be a bad time for developers
right what you end up with is a bunch of
differing workflows with long feedback
loops between code change and actually
being able to interact with their
application running in its runtime
environment right and so there's you
know overhead of maintaining this
workflow there's no consistency across
what should be a standard set of steps
this means that each developer has their
own method of running locally and and
this makes reusing and replicating
things in the development lifecycle
really hard and so if portability is one
of the key tenets of kubernetes and
containers and this is a problem that
needs to be solved and so that's where
scaffold comes into play so if you
remember scaffold was the command that
we ran a scaffold was a tool that we
used to get our quiz application up and
running on gke the scaffold is perfect
for standardizing and enabling iterative
development with containers and
kubernetes so with scaffold all
developers have to do is focus on step
one working with their code scaffold
takes care of the rest of the steps in
the middle and will not only give that
end point back to the developer will
actually stream out logs to the
developer to be able to allow them to
debug or make
Changez so let's actually switch back
into the demo and revisit our quiz
application so here I am with back in
the terminal and what we see here is
that scaffold dev this is a command that
will actually continue to run once our
application has been deployed and you'll
see here that it's actually streaming
back logs from my application now it's
pretty cool is that what it's also doing
is watching for changes so if I actually
want to change that quiz application
we're not having to re kind of you know
go through the process of building our
containers and and then applying those
kubernetes manifests all we have to do
is focus on the code so let's actually
go into the application okay so we'll
see here we're back at our application
directory so I'm actually going to go
into the index.html file I'm gonna make
some serious changes and there's nothing
more nerve-wracking than using vim in
front of 500 engineers but what I'm
gonna do is let's say that you'll see
here I initially wanted to quiz Wes but
maybe I want to quiz everyone in the
audience so what we're gonna do here is
change this and say hello io 124
attendees oh oh spelling is hard all
right cool all right so we're going to
change that file and great I've changed
my code and notice what I haven't done I
haven't gone into any docker file I
haven't gone into coop control but what
I have is this scaffold dev process
that's continuously watching for changes
in my code and now we've already
completed our deploy and build process
within 12 seconds and so our application
is now up and running again and so if we
revisit it we see that our code has
actually changed behind that same
endpoint has anyone brave enough to take
this one it's it's the one on the left
I'll just also pulse pair oh my goodness
it's the one on the right ok well that
that was not playing ok great so let's
actually cut back to the slides
so scaffold that's sorry
so scaffold is actually a pluggable
architecture so one thing to note about
that is that while you saw me deploy
into a kubernetes engine cluster those
running in the cloud we can actually use
scaffold with kubernetes environments
that are running locally in our laptop
so that's things like mini coop this
would result in a much faster deployment
kind of process but it all depends on
the culture of your kind of development
teams and if you're doing remote
development or local development what we
can also do is not only use our local
docker daemons so to build these docker
containers I actually was using docker
on my laptop but what you can do is
actually begin to outsource and push
some of that heavy lifting save our
battery with tools like Google cloud
build which is our managed build service
right so scaffold is a really useful
tool that makes for very happy and
productive developers right scaffold can
also work well for our automated
deployment pipelines but we'll get into
that first we want to dive into a few
tips so throughout the session we'll
just be sprinkling in if you are just
getting started what are some things
that you have to keep in mind and so our
first tips are around actually building
containers we have a tip on performance
and a tip on security so first around
performance make sure that you slim down
your container images so if you're
coming from the land of running
everything in virtual machines it can be
tempting to stuff everything that we
want into into containers and treat them
kind of like VMs that also makes for a
bad time because it makes for slower
pull times and if containers if their
value prop is really around increasing
deployment velocity slow image pull
times will only hamper teams and
especially if you're working at the
scale of hundreds if not thousands of
containers and micro services so an
approach to slim down container images
is to actually use multistage builds
this is basically an approach to build
your binaries in one container and then
copy that final binary to another
container without all of the build tools
SDKs or other dependencies that were
needed for the build to build that
artifact
once you do this then you can actually
deploy things faster as we have a more
lightweight container image the second
tip here is scan your images for
vulnerabilities so Google's hosted
container registry service provides
vulnerability scanning this is an alpha
feature but basically what this does is
that anything that you push to a docker
to the container registry in Google will
actually be scanned with this feature
enabled and so you can also enable it to
send you notifications should there be a
vulnerability via pub/sub along those
same lines when getting started
there are a swath of public images out
there in examples public docker hub
repos that are awesome for learning and
awesome for just kind of experimenting
with but they introduce inherent risk if
we start to take some of these public
containers their untrusted and
unverified and actually implement them
into our application sacks so avoid
doing that so now that we have
containers we're still you know now that
we have a container workflow for our
developers we're still missing how we
deploy containers into production at
scale in kubernetes right so if the end
goal of containers in kubernetes is to
get teams to move faster then a large
part of this actual magic starts
happening when we have automated build
and deployment pipelines across
environments for staging or production
now though let me let me preface this
with the opinion that there's no one
right way to do continuous integration
and continuous delivery also known as CI
CD but we can point to a few patterns
with an example pipeline here so if a
developer is pushing to a feature branch
or maybe tagging a release we should
expect the developer's workflow to end
there it should end up in a kubernetes
environment with a provided end point
assuming tests pass and the way that
this the way that it does this should be
an implementation detail and actually
hidden away from the developers so in
this scenario we're using cloud build
again in this case cloud build has build
triggers that can kick off a build with
multiple steps those steps can actually
include building the binaries maybe
running unit tests building the
container image and finally pushing that
out to a registry
Google cloud build is awesome because it
is able to provision and manage multiple
steps either sequentially or in parallel
right and so each of these steps
actually is executed within a docker
container and then across all of these
steps we have a shared workspace that
being said they're like you know there
are a lot of other tools in the
ecosystem that can fulfill this CI need
and some of these may already be present
in your existing workflows Jenkins is a
popular one for example that we see so
once we have this newly tagged image in
our registry we can now have that
trigger a deployment pipeline for
continuous delivery so cloud build
jenkins these tools can also perform
this functionality but in this example
we're using a tool called spinnaker to
perform our continuous delivery it's an
open source tool from Netflix that
Google is heavily invested in any CD
tools should be able to have a pipeline
triggered via a newly detected image and
kick off additional steps to checkout
kubernetes manifests maybe deploy them
into different environments like staging
production spinnaker here gives us
additional features like execution
windows maybe we only want to automate
deployment has a specific time or maybe
we want to enforce manual approvals from
our operations team before releasing
into production there's a whole bunch of
things that that spinnaker enables safe
roll backs being able to have a nice UI
around your actual pipeline and so it's
important to again when looking at these
different tools make sure that you're
choosing a tool not because of the hype
but because it actually fulfills the use
cases that you are looking to achieve
it's like I said cloud build can also do
this continuous delivery and deployment
phase so a couple tips when deploying
into production one very simple limit
access to production
you'd be surprised i've seen a handful
of customers that will give coop control
troops ETL access to their developers in
in production and what we actually want
to do is use some of GCPs and native
kind of isolation primitives and so in
this kind of diagram we're using a GCP
project which owns I am hierarchy to
actually limit access to the kubernetes
cluster and running in production right
so maybe we'll just give this access to
cluster operators and then give this
access to a service
account for our CI CD pipelines and then
second tip is to keep your kubernetes
configuration as code this is pretty key
because we'll want to one store the
existing state maybe we're template
izing our kubernetes manifests and want
to customize that depending on each
pipeline but we also want to track a
history of applied manifests and get in
source control management is a great way
to do that so now that we've covered
building containers we have to expose
them right to be able to interact with
them how do we actually expose them to
internal or external users so let's
actually jump back to the demo to take a
look at how kubernetes networking works
cool actually I'm going to close this so
I'm just ending the scaffold dev process
I was running earlier and I actually
want that to be redeployed so this will
actually not keep it in that iterative
development State we're going to run and
deploy that application without the kind
of feedback loop but in the meantime
let's actually switch our cluster so
communities are actually going to use
the not this cluster Thrun IDs cluster
okay so kubernetes networking regardless
of gke or elsewhere requires that a
single every single pod gets its own IP
address so let's look at that it's kind
of nice if you look at other
orchestration tools these might actually
require you to do port mapping or
something complex within which at scale
can be really difficult but you'll see
here we have I've actually running I'm
running the same application in a
different urban IDs cluster and I have
three pot UI pods in the database pod
and they all have their own IP address
so to achieve this kubernetes actually
the open source kubernetes doesn't
enforce any opinions and so there are
ways to achieve this one is to hard hard
code routes per node another is to use a
network overlay in place of routing
tables but ultimately it's you know this
this can run into limitations or
overhead to be able to just implement
base networking features but in gke we
actually get a VPC native way of
allocating IP addresses to pods so we
can within our Google V PC create a
known range for these pod IP addresses
these are known as IP aliases and then a
slash 24 from that range will be
assigned to each node to give two pods
that are running on that node so we can
actually look at that so I also have
three nodes in this cluster and we'll
look at the pod cider
given to each of these nodes and so
you'll see here that again what's what's
important to note about this is that
these are natively implemented in GCPs
Sdn right we are not having to say you
know creating a route per node to
actually implement this and say if
you're looking for an address in this
range here go to this node instead our
VPC actually handles that natively and
is aware of them and so what's really
great about that is that this is useful
when we're bumping up against quotas for
routes and large clusters or for
clusters with a hybrid connectivity
where we can actually advertise these
ranges right but one thing that's core
to know about kubernetes pods is that
they can come and go which means that
these IP addresses that you see here
will actually also do the same so
kubernetes gives us a stable way of
fronting the
pods with a concept called services
so let's actually look at some of our
services here
so let's probably start with our UI
service service types build upon each
other you'll see here that we have a
base cluster IP service and what this
means is that we have a stable virtual
IP internal to our kubernetes cluster
that fronts pods with this key value
these key value pairs right so we can
actually provide these key value pairs
otherwise known as labels in our
kubernetes manifests and so this service
is actually associated with a dynamic
map called endpoints so if we get
endpoints we'll actually see here that I
have a map of all of the pod IPS that
are running my UI and this endpoint map
is actually associated with the UI
service so if we scale that UI
deployment up and out of pod how many
replicas anyone out there six six I
think actually I didn't I don't think I
enable cluster auto scaling this cuz
they say let's let's keep it at four and
not go to not go to well so if we
actually look at endpoints again we'll
actually see some of the control loops
that Wes alluded to in action and so we
see that our endpoints object has
dynamically been updated to incorporate
this new pod that was created right and
so as we add more and more pod replicas
we can expect this map to be updated and
there's actually some magic under the
hood where we have a daemon running on
every single node configuring IP tables
on all of our kubernetes were nodes to
forward these stable VIPs to this one of
these pot IPS in the endpoints map right
and so this was really good we don't
have to think about how we configure
load balancing kubernetes kind of makes
this so just by declaring our service
object what I also want to call out is
that like I said services build upon
each other so we have an external IP
address for our UI pods as well and so
if we actually go into the UI we'll see
that we'll have network load balancers
provision for us and then these will
actually route to all of the nodes in
our cluster so use cluster has three
nodes and then we're back to the IP
tables forwarding to our actual pod
traffic so we've actually talked a lot
about how we
expose an individual service but what
happens when we have multiple services
which I'm sure your balance you have if
you're running in kubernetes engine how
do we have a single entry point to route
to those services so can we actually cut
back to the slides
so that's where the kubernetes ingress
object comes into play so in gke the
default ingress object is actually
implemented as our global HTTP low
balancer and so if you create an ingress
object you'll see here that I have a
service foo and a service bar we're
actually able to route users one method
is route by path so if we're going to
pass foo we're routed to our service foo
and then if we route to path bar
we're routed to our service bar and so
we also expect this to do a lot of basic
things at layer 7 like TLS termination
but what's really cool about gke
is that now we get to again like wes
mentioned integrate some of the great
GCP services with our kubernetes
applications so if we're using the
global HTTP slow bouncer we're actually
able to use things like cloud armor to
protect against do s attacks we're able
to use that Denia where proxy which is
basically enforcing a you know identity
based access control in front of
services cloud CDN and then I want to
call out one thing that's really cool
and very unique to Google cloud platform
and that's Kubb mci so what we can
actually do I think as you you know this
might not be getting started topic but
certainly a lot of customers have
directed their or headed in that
direction is running multiple clusters
in different geo regions and so with
Kubb mci we can actually configure our
load balancer not only to front multiple
services but to actually front multiple
different clusters across the globe and
so just a quick demo of that you'll see
here that I have 8 can we switch to the
demo you'll see here that I have two
kubernetes clusters one running in
uswest
and run one running in europe west and
so we also have our global load balancer
that has a single IP address right so we
have a single single entry point that is
fronting both of our kubernetes
engine clusters so if I go to this
because we are in wonderful San
Francisco we should actually be routed
to the US West one a cluster right and
what's really cool is that if we
actually go into a Europe West one be
virtual machine and actually hit that
same end point we're going to be we
should assuming you don't want to jinx
the demo we should be routed to our
Europe West cluster and what's really
great about this is that previously a
lot of people were trying to think about
how to implement this at the DNS layer
but what's you know with kubernetes
engine and our global load balancer can
actually think about this again at the
layer layer seven right so if we ping
this will actually see that we hit that
same IP address and we were served from
Europe OS 1b so no tricks up my sleeves
this is something that is just really
cool and again built into our actual
global load balancer using any cast
protocol great so going back to the
slides the last thing I want to wrap up
with as far as load balancing is really
making containers of first-class citizen
so as I mentioned before with IP aliases
we're able to front IP addresses with
known IP addresses through the V PC and
what we can actually do with that now is
implement something called Network
endpoint groups so as I mentioned before
there's a lot of IP tables magic in
traditional load balancing in kubernetes
which could lead to a bunch of extra
network hops and really a suboptimal
path and I think if you look on the
right here we'll see because we are
aware of pot IP addresses we're actually
able to configure them as backends to
our load balancers in Google cloud
platform and so what this makes for is
for an experience that makes low
balancing much like the way we do it
across VMs right we're able to health
check against the individual pods we're
able to route directly to them without
being rerouted through IP tables rules
and it really again kind of demonstrates
unique properties of google kubernetes
engine this is a feature in alpha but
certainly keep an eye on it
okay so the last tip I have around
networking is sometimes we need private
and internal applications to run on
kubernetes and so Google tributaries
engine also helps you to get enabled
with that via private clusters and
internal load balancers so private
clusters means that all of our virtual
machines run air containers are actually
running in a private VPC without any
access to the public Internet
so we can really harden our clusters
using private clusters and if we have
other applications and the same VPC that
are not running in kubernetes engine we
can actually also have Network load
balancers that are internal to a V PC
great so moving on to the next session
now that we have our app in containers
and we have a people way for people to
access them how do we handle a scenario
when a lot more people want to access
them and that's where auto scaling comes
into play so before we talk about auto
scaling it's paramount to introduce a
concept of requests and limits the first
tip here is use them um they define a
floor and ceiling for containers in pods
around resources like CPU and memory and
they actually inform how our control
plane schedules pods across nodes and
you'll see that they actually inform
auto scaling a quick note here is that
if you define limits for CPU your
containers will be throttled at that
limit but for memory it's incompressible
and so they will actually be killed and
restarted so really again it's it's it
does require a lot of understanding of
what are acceptable kind of resource
utilization of your containers cool so
the two most well-known auto scaling
paradigms are horizontal pod auto
scaling and cluster auto scaling so for
horizontal plot auto scaling can
actually target groups of pods and scale
on metrics like CPU or in gke we can
actually provide horizontal pod auto
scaling based on custom metrics so if
you're doing something like a task queue
and you want to track that and scale
more pods to handle let's say more work
you can configure HPA to do that we also
have the concept of cluster auto scaling
so eventually if you're scaling up a
numerous amount of pods you'll
eventually need to add more physical or
not visit virtual resources to your
kubernetes cluster to run those
and that's where cluster auto-scaling
comes into play pending pods that need
resources maybe they're not able to be
scheduled will trigger cluster
auto-scaling to spin out more machines
in our node pools and so these two auto
scaling paradigms are relatively new but
I do think it's important to call out
one is being able to scale workloads
vertically right so if we want if we
think of a compute intensive application
maybe like a database you know adding
more horizontal replicas won't
necessarily solve our issue and so maybe
we actually need to scale up the amount
of resources that that individual pod
has so with vertical plot auto scaling
you'll actually get recommendations that
can be either suggested or automatically
applied to resize the requests of your
pods and then on the right or yeah on
the right here you'll see that we also
have the ability to scale infrastructure
dynamically and so what this means is
that if we're if we have a certain set
of node pools in our kubernetes cluster
but we are you know we don't have any
resources to accommodate let's say a 16
CPU request we can actually use
something like node auto provisioning to
deploy a new node pool to handle that
request that really you know you can
scale out as many one CPU machines as
you want it's not going to fix that
right so node auto provisioning really
helps customers that are operating at
scale and can't necessarily keep track
of every single one of their hundreds of
micro services and requests and to have
no pools that fit each of those
workloads awesome so high availability
is important and I'm now gonna kick it
over to Wes
to tell us more about it awesome all
right so try to go through this
relatively quickly because we run a
little low on time I'm so H a we added a
number of new features actually the last
couple months around high availability
applications the first one is we added
regional persistent disk support to gke
quite simply what this does is it
replicates your persistent disks across
two zones in a region now why is this
nice well you don't have to handle
replication at the application layer and
worry about distributed databases you
can just store it all to a PD and Google
cloud platform will automatically
replicate those two different zones so
the abstraction happens at the storage
layer which just get you
get out of the box automatically the
other concepts around high availability
and is what we call regional clusters
this is a multi node control plane that
spreads both the kubernetes api server
and all of the control plant components
along with etsy d across three zones in
a region now the really nice thing about
regional clusters is that it increases
the uptime of the cluster to from two
and a half 9s to three and a half nines
and you get zero downtime upgrades
so in the zonal cluster case we have a
single node running your control plan it
will go down temporarily when we upgrade
the kubernetes version but if you're
using regional clusters for your
production workloads we'll do a one by
one upgrade and we'll always have two
two masters ready to serve any workloads
that come into the cluster the best part
about this is it's available at no
additional charge over the zonal
clusters we really want everyone to be
able to use multi master high
availability clusters for their
production apps so a few quick tips on
upgrades just so people understand how
this works on gke for the control plan
google engineers will constantly keep
this up to date we will upgrade behind
the scenes automatically this is not
something you can control outside of a
few maintenance window settings that
tell us when we can or cannot upgrade
your cluster now we we almost never
upgrade to the latest version of
kubernetes we'll upgrade you to a more
stable version that's had a bunch of
patch fixes and keep you on that and
slowly roll you up to the new to the
next version once in another version of
kubernetes comes out you can also
trigger this manually if you really want
the latest version of kubernetes by
going to our cloud console and clicking
upgrade now the upgrade for the control
plane happens automatically for nodes if
you enable auto upgrade it'll work for
that as well however if you don't enable
auto upgrade this is much more control
over when your kubernetes nodes get
upgraded to the next version and the
thing I wanted to call out is that your
cluster can work in this mixed mode
state via kubernetes backwards
compatibility so we can have nodes
running on 1/8 and a master that's
running on 1/10 and we actually won't
get to the next version of kubernetes
until we go in upgrade the nodes now
when you're
upgrading your nodes there's a few
things to think about you can do the the
rolling upgrade that just happens by
default and this is just by clicking the
the node upgrade button in the window or
you can do something called migration
with node pools there's a blog post
about this on the Google cloud platform
blog that goes into much more detail but
the short of it is you can actually
create another node pool on the newer
version of kubernetes split traffic over
to that node pool using Kubik little
drain and and cord on and then you can
trust test a little bit of the traffic
on that new version if you see your app
is misbehaving you still have the other
node pool that you can route back to the
previous version while you debug once
the new version looks good you scale
that one up and you scale the other node
pulldown and we actually see a lot of
production users doing this who want to
have a much more testable way of rolling
to a new version of kubernetes in the
last section is logging and monitoring
so I wanted to call out that @q con and
Europe this year in Copenhagen we
announced stackdriver for kubernetes
what this allows you to do is take open
source Prometheus instrumentation and
ingest that into stack drivers UI and
the really cool thing about this is it's
multi cluster aggregated and you get to
use all of the great stack driver
features like the pre-built dashboards
and the ability to do things like set
alerts so that you're notified when
something goes wrong in your cluster the
other feature that we have on gke is gke
audit logging so if people are changing
your cluster you want to figure out who
was the last person to deploy you can go
into our logging logging UI understand
either and see both pod level and
deployment level information along with
information about the resources as well
so if somebody added a note to your
cluster this is the screen that you
would go to in order to figure that out
now there are a ton more topics that we
just didn't have enough time to cover
and 50 minutes things like security
identity policy management there's a lot
of sessions that are going on that cover
these topics and much more depth Anthony
I will be outside to help answer any
lingering questions you have with that
trial gke and thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you